nous recevons jean louis touraine
députée les rangs même du rhône et
rapporteur de la loi bioéthique bonjour
et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
affirmé que l'autorisation de ces tests
génétiques exposés à une multitude de
risques notamment concernant
l'imprécision des résultats est-ce que
selon vous cette interdiction est utile
alors que ces textes c'est est on le
sait sont très facilement disponibles
sur internet
vous avez raison c'est quelque chose qui
est délicat comme décision parce que
d'un côté il est le désir de protéger
des personnes contre des informations
qu'il pourrait ne pas comprendre et et
en avoir d aqua niant mais de l'autre
côté il ya le risque de les priver
d'informations essentielles pour leur
santé à venir c'est ce qu'on appelle la
médecine prédictive et il vaut mieux
comme vous savez prévenir que guérir et
donc entre les deux je pense qu'il est
important de considérer que c'est
rarement par la prohibition qu'on trouve
la bonne solution
et donc je crois que la solution à venir
on voit bien que nos amis sénateurs ont
hésité entre les deux mais l'histoire
est pas définitivement écrite
il va y avoir une deuxième lecture et la
loi définitive n'interviendra qu'au tout
début d'été prochain d'ici là je crois
qu'ensemble nous travaillerons à
permettre l'accès à ces tests mais avec
un encadrement
c'est à dire que ce soit sous un
contrôle soin de médecins soient de
d'experts en génétique des ce qu'on
appelle des conseillers en génétique et
que ainsi les personnes puissent avoir
le bénéfice des informations mais sans
avoir des inquiétudes des informations
tronquées des mauvaises interprétations
et parfois même des résultats douteux
vous savez bien souvent par exemple
s'agissant de risque de maladie
ce que dit c'était c'est au lieu d'avoir
un risque sur 10000 de faire tel m'a dit
vous avez un risque sur 1000 mah risque
sur 1000 c'est quand même pas une grande
fréquence sauf que certaines personnes
vont comprendre
oulala je suis très exposés ceux ci
aient paniqué donc il faut effectivement
qu'il ya quelqu'un pour leur expliquer
d'autre part ces dettes génétique donne
accès à la connaissance sur la paternité
évidemment et on sait bien qu'il ya des
fois des paternités qui ne sont pas
celles que l'on imagine il faut pouvoir
maîtriser les conséquences de tout cela
est donc aujourd'hui la prohibition ne
veut pas tenir puisque les gens font
appel à des tests dans tous les pays qui
nous entourent
la france est un des très très très
exceptionnelle pays développés avec la
pologne en en effet exactement où les
tests ne sont pas donc que font les
français
eh bien il envoie un petit peu de leur
salive dans l'un quelconque des pays qui
nous entourent
avec quelques dizaines d'euros et en
retour ils ont des raisons génétiques
mais ils les ont dans des conditions
d'incertitude de nom commentaires
d'imprécisions et quelquefois même des
choses qui sont fausses
parce qu'elles n'ont pas été développés
dans un cadre médical et scientifique
rigoureux et donc je crois que oui il
faudra sortir de la prohibition qui
génère toujours du marché noir des
mauvaises conditions et des dérapages
négatif mais levé cette interdit de veut
pas dire laisser tout faire
ça veut dire un encadrement bien
organisé et ce pour quoi il va falloir
développer en france déconseillant gène
tic ce qu'il y en a si peu que pour
l'instant on peut pas faire comment dire
satisfaction pour la totalité des
personnes qui désirent ses connaissances
qui leur appartiennent d'un certain côté
puisque c'est le patrimoine génétique de
chacun qui est alors analysé le grand
volet de ce projet de loi bioéthique
s'est évidemment l'extension de la pma
toutes les femmes les femmes homosexuels
les femmes célibataires
les sénateurs ont choisi de réserver il
quelques jours la prise en charge de la
pma par l'assurance maladie aux seules
demandes fondées sur la base d'un
critère médical quel est votre regard
sur cette position sénatoriales alors un
grand merci aux sénateurs d'avoir
accepté la pma pour tout ça devenait
difficile dans notre pays de dire
mesdames qui vivaient seuls ou en
couples de femmes vous avez le droit
d'adopter des enfants
vous êtes parfaitement apte à les élever
vous êtes de très bonnes mères mais on
vous interdit de faire ses enfants
c'était un petit peu difficile à tenir
composition donc enfin cet interdit la
va être levé et les femmes pourront
quand elle le souhaite solliciter une
pme pour autant il ne faut pas qu'il y
ait égalité et là je dis - merci à mes
collègues sénateurs parce qu'ils
introduisent une inégalité si ils ne
permettent pas qu'il y ait une prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie dans la
mesure où les femmes fortunées n'ont
aucun souci pour le faire sur leurs
deniers personnels
mais les femmes qui sont plus en
difficulté ne pourront pas y avoir accès
et donc on va se retrouver avec une
ségrégation se pare d'argent qui n'est
pas souhaitable pour ces questions là
par ailleurs le conseil d'état lui même
le gouvernement l'assemblée nationale
tous se sont prononcés pour une prise en
charge qui d'ailleurs est un montant
financier très très bas très peu élevé
et c'est pas ça qui va du tout mettre en
péril l'équilibré social donc il nous
semble que il faut accorder l'accès à
toutes les femmes d'une prise en charge
par la sq sociale il faut ajouter
d'ailleurs que ce n'est pas du tout une
nouveauté contrairement à ce que
certains disent là sur ce qu'on appelle
l'assurance maladie qu'on devrait mieux
appeler assurance santé depuis très
longtemps finance beaucoup de choses qui
ne sont pas des actes thérapeutiques
quand l'assurance maladie paie pour des
actions de prévention pour pour des ivg
pour que ce ne sont pas des actes
thérapeutiques de la même façon la pma
n'est pas un acte thérapeutique pour
personne même dans les couples
hétérosexuels
ça ne traite pas la stérilité les
stérilités reste ça ne fait qu'une
compensation compensation pour des gens
qui ont une maladie ou compensations
pour des gens qui sont dans un couple
inapte à procréer donc on a bien compris
que sur ce point de la prise en charge
par l'assurance mais reviendra dessus
l'assemblée nationale reviendra dessus
les débats sont plutôt apaisée jusque là
au sénat le projet de loi bioéthique va
arriver à l'assemblée nationale sans
doute courant mi avril
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
s'attendre à une telle sérénité des
débats
elle était députée oui puisque la
première lecture a été sereine
je crois que c'est grâce au travail de
deux ans à peu près de préparation avec
des commissions démission une
information de la totalité des députés
nous avons pu ainsi éviter des
polémiques inutiles
chacun a eu la possibilité de s'exprimer
et il est vrai que là dessus personne
une vérité absolue
donc il faut avoir du respect pour des
points de vue différents mais on ne peut
pas définitivement rester sur des
positions ultra traditionnelle qui qui
refusent d'intégrer certains des progrès
tout progrès n'est pas bon a enregistré
mais on peut aussi dire qu'il est tout
aussi des raisins peut dire qu'on
n'accepte aucun progrès voilà la
l'assemblée nationale a accepté que sur
certains sujets il y ait des compromis
et justement il n'y a pas eu de
polémique
vive entre les uns et des autres je sais
plus tellement parmi les appelés les
amendements qui sont proposés par les
députés de la majorité il ya l'ouverture
de la procréation médicalement assistée
aux hommes transgenres la question des
enfants nés intersexe ou encore le fait
d'accorder au centre privé ou droit de
proposer une auto converse conservation
des ovocytes
c'est des questions qui sont quand même
très clivante on s'imagine bien que les
débats vont être houleux tous trois ont
dit et je le répète personne sur ces
sujets d'une vérité absolue
moi j'aime beaucoup cette phrase de
condenser qui disait que la vérité
appartient à ceux qui la recherche et
non point ceux qui prétendent à détenir
il y a donc nécessité de débats pour
autant nous le savons tous je crois ou
presque tous ces questions là seront
l'objet d'avancés
si ce n'est aujourd'hui au moins dans
les années toute prochaine car il n'est
pas possible de continuer à marginaliser
des populations par exemple vous avez
cité des personnes intersexe rendement
ou les personnes
transgenres ils nous disent aujourd'hui
qu'ils se considèrent comme était
considéré les homosexuels il y à 40 ans
et donc on ne peut pas laisser ces
personnes vivent dans la souffrance dans
la marginalité
on doit leur prêter attention les
entendre et leur accorder des droits
égaux aux autres personnes à l'adoption
définitive de ce projet de loi
bioéthique pourrait intervenir avant
l'été 2020 merci beaucoup à jean louis
tourenne d'être venu pour ne pas te
répondre à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député la république en marche
du rôle et co rapporteur de ce projet de
loi bioéthique